finally a shocker from american figure
skater alyssa liu who announced her
retirement at the age of 16 years old
lou is a two-time u.s national champion
she won her first title at age 13 break
breaking tara lipinski's record as the
youngest national champion two weeks ago
lou won a bronze medal at the world
champions she wrote on instagram i feel
so satisfied with how my skating career
has gone i'm going to be moving on with
my life
she added she i mean right yeah
at 16 she decides that she added she
will probably spend her spare time with
friends and family and study she made
her olympic debut in beijing back in
february she finished seven she's been
very outspoken about mental health and
she's taken the lead from others like
simone biles nami osaka serena williams
they've all talked about the importance
of mental health i admire that she's
doing this at 16 i also like that she
said i've been skating since i was five
right that's a very very long i know
we've done what i wanted to do right we
look at her age and we say she's fairly
young but she's been doing this for many
many years and if she's able to do it
and retire
all all true but it is a little funny to
retire at 16. i retired from
baskin-robbins
[Laughter]
wrote a formal note and everything i
feel like i've retired
in my life at this point